so we have lots of physical
characteristics beauty is one of them
and the question is what is the beauty
premium what what do people that are
more beautiful get away with it other
people
don't or do they and the answer is yes
they do and all kinds of reasons for
that some of the reasons have of course
have to do in the dating or marriage
market right and we have this
evolutionary analysis of the healthiness
of people and things like symmetry and
skin without blemishes and all kinds of
things like that and basically create
queues for people to think about how
evolutionary fit that person is so in
the dating market of course people who
are more beautiful and we infer from
that that a more evolutionary fit are
more attractive but does it also
happened to be the case in non
reproducing reproduction markets like
the job market it turns out that even in
those markets it is the case so more
beautiful people do get all kinds all
kinds of benefits one of the nice papers
on this was actually written about
height and not about beauty but the
principles are the same so there is a
height premium tall people make more
money than short people I'm five nine
not so good for me taller people make
make more money but in that particular
paper they looked at the age in which
people shut up
and they looked at their final height so
in general people who are tall at age
forty will probably also tall each age
17 and 15 but not everybody there are
some people who shoot up in height
earlier and some people shoot up in
height later and what they found out was
that the way height was concerned it was
about height at puberty rather than
final height so if you shut up and
height earlier on but then you stop so
your final height is not that high but
when you were in puberty you're
relatively tall people still got the
premium for as if they were tall and if
you were not all during puberty and then
you just became taller later you don't
have this
a premium now what they suggest is that
it's not just about the final attribute
it's not just that we look at tall
people's a head is a tall person let me
give them more money but partially it
has to do with self confidence
that's what happened is that aids
puberty the tall people basically get to
experience more confidence and the
shorter people get to experience less
confidence and that confidence stays
later whether or not they stay they stay
tall and I think the same thing would
happen if we could do this study on
beauty that yes if you're beautiful I
would look at you I would say hey you're
just pleasant to stay around with you're
probably qualified in all kinds of ways
like that but if you were beautiful at
puberty or at a young age and you got
lots of attention and so on it might be
the case that you now have confidence
that comes from that so it's not just my
perception of you it's but it's your own
definition of yourself that is changing
because of that and that would be like a
self-fulfilling prophecy
so maybe the advice is to let all kids
during puberty think that they are
beautiful something like